Salut ! Aujourd'hui je vous donne la solution au défi d'hier.
Alors, si vous n'avez pas vu le défi d'hier, regardez-le avant puisque là je donne la solution. Vous ne pourrez donc plus chercher après.
La solution va vous paraître un petit peu tordu, mais elle fonctionne à 100%, j'ai toujours réussi à me faire payer des verres avec ce défi.
La pièce est mise sous une tasse et vous affirmez que vous allez pouvoir récupérer la pièce sans toucher à la tasse.
La technique que j'emploie est très simple.
Je tape avec ma main sous la table et je fais semblant d'attraper la pièce comme au travers.
Bon, personne n'y crois je vous rassure.
Je garde le poing serré et je dis à la personne c'est bon, j'ai récupéré la pièce.
Elle n'est plus sous la tasse.
Tu peux vérifier, elle n'est plus en dessous.
Au "Tu peux vérifier, elle n'est plus en dessous", personne n'y croit et il y a toujours quelqu'un pour soulever la tasse pour vérifier.
Et là faut être prêt, faut être prêt à attraper la pièce à ce moment là.
Et une fois que vous l'avez attrapée vous avez rempli votre défi et dire "C'est bon regarde, j'ai attrapé la pièce sans toucher à la tasse exactement comme je l'avais dit!"
Oui c'est tordu, mais ça fonctionne et ça permet d'avoir des verres gratuits et de réussir un défi.
Et maintenant, l'énigme d'aujourd'hui !
Comme aujourd'hui on est dimanche, je me suis dit cette énigme numéro trois, pouvait changer un petit peu.
Nous allons parler de Franck, Will et Claude.
Vous ne connaissez pas ces trois personnes: Franck, Will et Claude et pourtant
Franck est le frère de Will, Will est le frère de Claude et pourtant Claude n'est pas le frère de Franck.
Je répète: Franck est le frère de Will, Will est le frère de Claude, mais Claude n'est pas le frère de Franck !
Comment ça se fait ?
Il y a comme toujours une solution très simple et très logique.
Vous la trouverez j'en suis sûr ce dimanche. Si vous avez la réponse, n'en parlez pas dans les commentaires, mais plutôt mettez un...
POUCE EN L'AIR !
Comme ça, ça nous permet de voir tout de suite le pourcentage de personnes qui ont trouvé la solution par rapport au nombre de vues.
Parlez-en dans les commentaires sans donner la solution !
Je vous en supplie !
Profitez du soleil, passez un excellent été !
N'oubliez pas de vous abonner avant de partir, parce que le Mental Vlog c'est une vidéo par jour pendant un an.
Et rendez-vous demain à 17h.
Ciao !